so I watched a video where you spoke on
directors on directing that was the
title of the of the series and you used
an analogy of a shredder and you said
that you've seen a lot of people maybe
that you know they're kids or other
people that are beautiful actors
beautiful bodies beautiful faces come
through Hollywood and then you see them
changed a few years later because they
came or they wanted to be in the
business for the show but they didn't
realize what the business was and you
said the business is the shredder and
you don't really come out the same I
believe that or have experienced that if
you don't have the understanding of this
industry and the systems of the industry
without a stroke of divine intervention
it's difficult to not only be successful
but to survive a friend my was an
executive at a studio and I were talking
one day and he was we're talking about
females in the business and he's a lot
of women come through his office you
know and they're sent my friends or at
the audition and he sees audition at
whatever he says I know it's it's hard
but it's harder for women I said what do
you mean he says well let's take it this
to put it this way in terms of I'll tell
you two example he said women 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25
26 27 28 29 30 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38
so I'll give you an example he said
Harrison Ford can be a lead in the film
and have a female love interest that's
in her late 30s early 40s it said name
one female actress in her 70s that could
have a male Copart lead in his late 30s
low 40s name one it would cause a lot of
stir I think that we may not be seeing
that in anything soon
you